skydiving in dubai is spectacular it's
unlike any other place i've skydived
once i'm in the sky
it's just like i'm like anyone else
[Music]
my name is jared martin i'm 26 years old
i'm from seattle washington and i'm a
skydiver
my family's history is all skydiving my
grandfather was a skydiver which led to
my father being a skydiver and then my
sister is made of skydive and my aunts
and uncles are all skydivers of course
naturally myself skydiving runs in the
family well i've been skydiving for
over 10 years now i did my first skydive
with my father at age nine and then i
started on my solo career at age 15.
i've been loving skydiving ever since
i've been disabled for eight years i was
in a
weird parachuting accident when i was 18
years old and
it was a tragic accident but i think in
the end it really made me stronger and
maybe even a better person who knows
when i was injured
what really saved me was the
family-like attributes that skydiving
has with each other and there was no
time for me to be depressed there's no
time for me to be sad my friends and
family really made it an easy transition
to what would be the next chapter of my
life
i first moved to dubai in 2013 i
developed some interest from
skydive dubai and i got the opportunity
to come out here full time
it's quite a production for me to
skydive i mean the skydive itself have
fallen out of an airplane that's easy
but it's all of the things that lead up
to getting in the airplane and you know
getting back in my wheelchair i couldn't
do without my friends and they're
they're absolutely incredible
the views from the height that we jump
from you can see
everything it's one of those things you
just have to try it
it's indescribable
[Music]
there's been a couple adaptations of
equipment that i've had to use for me to
be able to skydive and one of them is my
leg retention device it keeps my legs
separated
yet it keeps them from flapping wildly
out of control
the landing
is one of the most asked questions that
i get i can't stand up my landings like
most able-bodied skydivers because i
just kind of do a glorified tuck and
roll essentially it's as graceful of a
landing as you can as you can get i have
probably about close to 5 000 jumps
total and the freedom of being able to
repeat skydive after skydive while i've
been in dubai really racked up the jump
numbers quite fast
[Music]
when i'm in the zone and i'm like really
like doing my thing it's nice to know
that there's people that i'm helping
whether it be disabled people
trying to get them to do whatever they
think they can do because if i can do
skydiving
anybody can do anything and whether it
be someone disabled or not i think it
inspires
everyone to
push themselves to do things that they
never thought was possible if you think
about it like some guy in a wheelchair
skydiving that doesn't seem possible
[Music]
you